hello and welcome to the take with
sophie ridge live at nine here in the
heart of westminster
well in the east of ukraine the barrage
is continuing without let up russian
aggression and the war in ukraine has
completely transformed how we view
global threats and that's meant big
questions for nato about membership
about troops and weapons and it's also
meant big questions here at home about
defence spending and whether or not it
needs to increase so there is plenty for
us to get stuck into as we bring you
takes from all sides over the next 60
minutes
i see an expansion of
the alliance which is exactly the
opposite of what putin wanted he wanted
less nato he's getting more the pm was
with other western leaders as nato
confirmed a big increase in forces and
that meant at pmq's it was the deputies
in charge
i generally point out to her that we
want this prime minister to go on a lot
longer than she wants the leader of the
labour party
where was the honorable member when the
situation in afghanistan on a sun
lounger that's where the honourable
member was
pretty electric her exchange as dominic
raab stood in for boris johnson and
angela ranger rayner deputised for care
stamina we'll find out what our viewers
panel made of pmq's too and there they
are we can have a look at them hello
everyone quick wave uh if you can hear
me we will be hearing
more from the panel at later on on the
program we'll also have some top guests
including the home office safeguarding
minister rachel mclean the shadow chief
secretary to the treasury pat mcfadden
we'll be talking to the former deputy
chief of the defence staff sir simon
male plus we'll be talking to the labour
mp rosie duffield plus much more decides
all coming up on the take
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening well we're often told that
keeping people safe is the first
responsibility of government how much to
spend on defence has always been a
thorny subject now more than ever as the
world feels more dangerous than it has
in decades well it's top of the agenda
today in madrid where the pm is meeting
other nato leaders there's plenty of
domestic politics though too whether
it's scottish independence the start of
the parliamentary investigation into
partygate and a debate over whether
abortion should be part of the british
bill of rights so let's crack straight
on we're going to start with the best
bits of the week so far
what we're going to be doing now is is
talking about
what more we can do as an alliance to
support the ukrainians i generally point
out to her that we want this prime
minister to go on a lot longer than she
wants the leader of the labour party
where was the honorable member when the
situation in afghanistan on a sun
lounger that's where the honourable
member was i take no lectures from the
honourable member when it comes to doing
your job what i will never do is allow
scottish democracy to be a prisoner of
boris johnson or any prime minister will
you block our plans to have another
referendum we
you can take it
this way we certainly think that uh our
plan for a stronger economy works better
when the uk is together if vladimir
putin was hoping uh that he would be
getting less nato on uh on his western
uh front as a result of his uh
unprovoked illegal invasion of of
ukraine uh he's been proved completely
wrong i'd revel in the opportunity for
the people of this country to have more
than just by-elections to see what they
think of this government will the
government back my bill to ban the use
of nda's in cases of sexual harassment
bullying and misconduct will he accept
the cross-party amendment to his
forthcoming bill of rights which
enshrines the women's right to choose in
law
[Laughter]
[Applause]
she talks about working people
she talks about working people
she talks about
well plenty for the prime minister to
think about and of course for the
government
to assess too we can talk now to our
first guest the home office minister for
safeguarding rachel mclean on the
programme thank you very much for being
please with us today and i just want to
start by talking about ukraine with big
global affairs huge uh day to day with
nato effectively reassessing
its defence capability in the light of
that russian aggression whether it's
membership whether it's treat numbers
given the war and given the aggression
from russia do we need to look at
increasing defense spending in the uk as
well well clearly it's an incredibly
dangerous period that we are facing and
that's why the prime minister is is
there speaking to
nato allies and at this stage we must
all work together with our international
partners um putin has decided to to turn
himself into an aggressor threatening a
sovereign and peaceful democratic nation
and what he succeeded in doing is
uniting g7 and nato partners in in our
mission to defeat him and to defend
ukraine so on the question of spending i
mean clearly
in order to defend our nation freedom
isn't free we do have to spend money
and that's why it is important that we
are spending our nato commitments we're
spending that percentage of gdp which
we've committed to doing but we will
always always need to look at our
security posture
and how we fund our armed forces i think
if you look at the commitment that we've
given the weapons the assistance that
we've given to the ukraine in order to
help them defeat putin i think we have
been at the forefront
of military aid there in the uk and we
should be proud of that so just looking
at the threat level which i think we can
agree has clearly gone up uh recently
looking at what russia has been capable
of doing the question i guess is about
the response to that ben wallace told
okay burly this morning that his
settlement was done before russia
invaded ukraine russia is very very
dangerous on the world stage the world
is less secure than it was two three
years ago and it is not looking likely
to change for the rest of the decade
that is the moment in the middle of the
decade to say we should commit to
increased funding do you agree with him
well look i think ben wallace is it is
his job as a secretary of state for
defence to call for more spending and to
make sure that we are defending our
nation um i think what the secretary of
state for defense is saying that he's
he's got the settlement that he's got at
the moment which actually is the biggest
that the armed services have had since
the end of the video he's basically
saying it's not going to be enough going
forward
before russia and greater ukraine
absolutely and the world has changed and
we must always continue to to review
that but one thing is for sure we will
defend ukraine's right to exist we've
been at the forefront of the defense
efforts to protect ukraine at the
ukrainian citizens
not only with weapons but also with the
other types of assistance that enables
them to get food to their citizens and
we'll continue to doing that okay
now and with your hat on the
safeguarding minister hat on the
metropolitan police has been put in
special measures is it fit for purpose
i think it's a really
worrying time i have to say that in my
role i work with some absolutely
brilliant met officers and it is really
important to say that
there are incredibly good people who can
come forward to serve in the met police
but look we agree we agree with the
inspectorate's report that's why we
supported it we expect the police to
focus on the basics we expect them to
focus on keeping the streets safe and
tackling crime so it is right that this
process has started and they must be
held to account and now the mayor of
london does really need to step up and
get a grip on this improvement you say
it's worrying
what what really in particular is
worrying you
well look you know the inspector has
come forward and will come forward with
the report but we've we've all seen of
course we've all seen what's in the
media we're all aware of the the tragic
events surrounding sarah everard's
murder many other cases the offices in
charing cross and that's just to name
but a few and some of the failings are
are widespread they're they're well
documented and and it's clear that we
expect the police to do that basic job
of protecting the public and are they
doing that
they're there are clearly some problems
there which is why the inspector has put
them into this process and that and now
we really do need the process uh those
those governance and accountability
measures to to take place more than some
problems though isn't it i mean look you
had a serving police officer murder
sarah everard as you said the messages
sent by people in sharon cross i mean
this is like joking about domestic
violence most of the things you know i
read those messages they're absolutely
sick they are they are they must have
felt sick absolutely they're absolutely
horrific and completely unacceptable
they're a sexy problem in the matter and
so so if you if you just look at what
the home secretary has done she has
immediately commissioned a review on
that the events following
everest murder we do take that
incredibly seriously do you think there
is a sexism problem in the med police
well i think it's not for me to comment
it is obviously we have seen evidence of
sexism and we must deal with that and i
think the met themselves have said
that's unacceptable then they must root
it out but we do need them to now set
out a plan of how they intend to tackle
these problems whether it's sexism
whether it's any other problems
because actually we expect a police
force in london our biggest police force
that by the way is receiving record
amounts of funding uh rece receiving
funding to recruit new officers we must
make sure that it's fit for purpose is
it for purposes right now
well what we've seen at the moment is
some severe failings are set out in the
process so obviously it needs to it
needs to improve
and now i just want to talk to you a bit
about abortion because of course we've
seen this the overturning of roe versus
wade in the states so the landmark
ruling that made abortion legal there
now it's obviously shaken a lot of women
as a result and some labour mps are now
calling for the right to an abortion to
be included in the british bill of
rights is that something that you
personally would like to see
so what we see in in this country is we
have a settled position on abortion uh
when it's brought forward to parliament
it is a matter of conscience it's always
a free vote and i think that system has
served us well i would be reluctant
actually for the reasons that the deputy
prime minister set out today at prime
minister's questions to bring it into a
judicial system whereby it's litigated
within the courts and why is that just
explain to people who might not watch
pmq's why well i think that what we have
here is a system where elected
representatives can
set the law around abortion we have a
system
in the united kingdom that that
preserves those rights of women to have
an abortion that's a settled position
it's existed for a very long time and
that i believe safeguards the rights of
women to have an abortion i believe
that's my personal view it should be a
free choice and i've always voted for
the rights of women to have an abortion
it is always a free vote it's always a
matter of conscience when it comes to
parliament and i think that's the right
way for it to be settled in this country
i mean i guess you know you say it
should be mps effectively who decide i
just want to read to you the words of
danny kruger concerts mp who said that
some of his parliamentary colleagues
think that women have an absolute right
to bodily autonomy in this matter
whereas i think in the case of abortion
that right is qualified by the fact that
another body is involved are you
comfortable that with that that women
don't have an absolute right to body
autonomy i think on a subject like this
it's an incredibly sensitive subject and
people are able to disagree respectfully
within parliament but ultimately i guess
that's why some people think that
actually having mps decide on the right
to abortion makes them nervous because
they effectively don't necessarily
always trust the decision that some mps
will come up
mps reflect democracy they if reflect
the wishes of their constituents we've
had a settled position on abortion we
have a settled way of it being available
to women
in this country
it's a fundamental part of health care
in this country it will remain so and i
believe that that is the right way to
continue to protect those rights of
women if they want to have an abortion
okay thank you so much for being on the
program uh good to talk rachel mclean uh
they're talking to us today
well as you saw a little earlier at the
beginning of the programme it was
labour's deputy leader who was standing
in for her boss kirsten at prime
minister's questions today and that
meant that it was the deputy prime
minister dominic raab who had a bit of
fun claiming she was more interested in
getting his job and she gave plenty back
as well accusing him of being on a sun
lounger during the afghanistan crisis
last summer well we can talk to uh pat
mcfadden now and get labour's take the
party shadow chief secretary to the
treasury thank you very much for being
with us and we've been talking about the
war in ukraine and the russian
aggression on the programme today now
labour has said it would support an
increase in defence spending what
increase are you calling for
russia's invasion of ukraine has caused
every country i believe to
have to re-examine
its assumptions about defence its needs
and its capabilities in germany they
call this the turning point
they're in a very different position
from us
but i think every country
needs to do that afterwards and that's
what we would do in government is what
we did when we were in government before
when we had a sustained
increase in defence spending
it's often said in parliament the first
duty of government is to protect its
citizens that's what we believe
that's what we'll do
and that's our position so what level
should it rise to them you can't pick a
level now because i think you've got to
have a proper assessment of your needs
and capabilities we're committed to the
two percent uh that nato wants we're
very committed to nato nato was founded
i mean that's what the government's
effectively committed to meeting the
late nato targets as well i'm just
trying to unpick you know you say it
should be a turning point there should
be an increase in defense against
funding
what's the level you know ben wallace
reportedly wants 2.5 percent of gdp by
2028. there's another target for you
know 0.5 percent plus inflation what
what's labour's there's lots of targets
around what people say what is labour's
target our position is you've got to
have a proper fundamental strategic
defense review of your needs and
capabilities you do that in government
and then you decide your budget but one
thing is clear we will protect the
british public and we will fulfill our
responsibilities to nato which we're
very proud to have played a big role in
founding with the post-war labour
government it's difficult though if you
can't come up with a number isn't it too
i don't think so i think it would be a
bit facile to be honest to come up with
a number here with you
when we haven't done the strategic
defense review that we need to do in
government that's the right way to do
this okay
now just talk about abortion for a
minute um again it came up in the house
of commons early today at prime
minister's questions it's it's a very
live topic after the overturning of bray
versus wade estella crucially the labour
mp is calling for the fundamental right
to an abortion to be included in the
british bill of rights do you support
that
this has
always been an individual issue in
parliament
not a party whipped issue it's important
to say that so the viewers know that i'm
giving you
my view not necessarily you know the
rest of the labor party's view the view
i've always taken as a legislator is
that there should be
legal provision for abortion in the
country
that's what the law of the land should
be that's the way i've always voted on
this issue and if we have future votes
on it i expect that's the way i will
vote again i think the
supreme court decision taken in the
united states last week
is
a hugely retrograde step
that will cause enormous difficulty and
pain for women in the united states i
wouldn't like to see
us go to that position here so i think
it's important that we maintain
safe and legal provision for abortion in
this country and that's the way i would
vote in parliament okay okay it's
interesting different takes when you and
rich mclean both of course are
supporting of the right to abortion but
i guess just different
routes to getting there and i just want
to talk a little bit about the labour
party because um tony blair said this
week on a podcast i support what kirsten
was doing he has moved the party
significantly the central problem is
what are the ideas that going to stop
this relegation and put the uk on an
upward path jeremy corbyn took over the
labour party the conservative party
became a brexit party the strong center
ground that you need to drive practical
radical solutions was weakened there has
been a gaping great hole where ideas
should be do you agree with that there's
been a gaping great hole where ideas
should be i'll tell you where i think
there's a situation vacant in british
politics for a party that combines
enthusiasm for wealth creation and
prosperity
with social justice that's where the
labour party is at its best that's where
i think we should plant our flag
a big reason
why the country is facing a lot of the
problems that it's facing right now with
the cost of living and inflation and so
on is
a lack of economic growth over many many
years not just over a year or two over
many years that's made us less
prosperous it's made us more vulnerable
so what we've got to do is combine that
enthusiasm for prosperity and wealth
creation
with the things that the labour party's
always believed in good public services
a good nhs
a good education system and so on we're
the party of both social justice and
prosperity and that's where we should
plant our flag it's that's where we
should plant our flag do you not think
kirsten has already planted the flag in
that position he's engaged in a huge
process of transformation last week we
had the best by-election result that
we've had in 10 years we had the best
vote that we had in wakefield for 20
years so we've made huge progress
worse there's more to do so kirsten also
told the new statesman this week that
we're starting from scratch the slate is
wiped clean i mean he's been labor
leader for two years don't you think you
need to when are you going to start
filling in the slate well we've got
plenty of policies the government's just
adopted our policy on the windfall tax
of course there's more to come what
kirsten are saying by that is that the
program that we fought and failed to win
uh on in 2019 is clearly not going to be
the program going forward you need to
come up with another of course that's
true so we are
making great progress since that
terrible defeat at two and a half years
ago uh and everybody knows there is more
to do to get ourselves into a winning
position i would say we're in a
competitive position right now which is
great progress but of course we've got
more to do okay thank you very much
being on the uh program uh pat mcfadden
uh there so
we've now heard from both the government
and labor so we can try and work out a
little bit of what we learned where
we're standing so far we can talk as
usual to your deputy political editor
sam coates sam good to see you what are
your main takeaways from the interviews
so far well oddly enough despite the big
issues that are being discussed scottish
independence to spend spending the thing
that's most live it strikes me in the
commons today even is the issue of
abortion suddenly back on the agenda
because of the verdict on friday from
the us supreme court uh
overturning roe v wade now this has led
mps actually in all parties to question
whether britain's own abortion laws are
strong enough whether or not they too
could be overturned now the british
right to abortion was enshrined in a
1967 act that currently allows uh
abortion up to 24 weeks the question
that's being posed by stella creasy and
some other mps is whether or not instead
of there being certain circumstances in
which it's legal whether or not there
should just be a fundamental right and
that attached to the new bill of rights
that dominic raab is proposing so that's
the debate you're going to hear about
but it's important to understand the
criticism that the government has of
that they worry that if this is
introduced and there is a right to an
abortion then that right might conflict
with some of the other rights even in
the bill of rights which would say for
instance that there's a right to life
and if those two things are challenged
it would end up in court and it would be
for a judge to decide which was more
important the right to life or the right
to an abortion and there is a worry
amongst ministers that this issue of
abortion could end up in the courts
rather than decided by elected
politicians and that would actually take
us further down the american route
rather than sticking to the system that
we have at the moment i did generally
find it quite interesting actually
talking to both rachel mclean and pat
mcfadden who i think have basically the
same view on abortion and very genuinely
held views too that they believe in the
right to abortion but just different
ways of trying to enshrine that right
and protecting it effectively that's
right and i think that most mps that i
talk to believe that there is a
consensus around the current situation
but the problem is that you start to
unpick that you never quite know where
you're going to end up interesting stuff
uh sam uh always good to talk we'll talk
to you later on the programme uh as uh
well
now some breaking sporting news oh no
sorry apologies
that was
if you are watching the tennis or
interested in tennis pause that that was
a wrong
auto cue so don't worry it's still live
we will bring you the andy murray result
as soon as we have it don't worry in the
meantime we'll go to the break
[Music]
back to the politics now and it was a
very lively uh prime minister's
questions as it always is when angela
rainer is facing off against uh dominic
ron we can find out
what uh how it went down with our
viewers uh panel our regular panel of
viewers that we have on the show there
they all are good to see everybody now
we've got people from across the uk and
also critically across the political
spectrum so it tends to be a great
snapshot i guess of what people
are thinking and i'm really interested
to know what you made of today's
pmq's session let's go to hannah
underwood first shall we now uh hannah
is a labour supporter uh you are from
hartford aren't you hannah uh what did
you make of the two understudies
i thought it was really lively i really
enjoyed it quite invigorating really
political debate
if i had to pick a winner i'd probably
say that angela rainer really uh sunk
some points home she she promised about
boris johnson fleeing the country
she's talking about high taxes that
everybody's suffering at the moment and
i think
yeah she scored the most points
so hannah reckons uh that it was angela
rayner who came out on top tim let's
talk to tim warren next shall we tim you
describe yourself as a progressive
centrist you're coming talking to us
from dorset who do you think came out on
top
i think uh i think angela rainer
probably came out on top what started
but it was quite a light-hearted um
humorous exchange
but there are outcomes from the from the
exchange and particularly the wink there
was a wink from dominic rob
and i just think that sums up how to
touch the government are
um
what was it condescending was it
mcchismo was it sexist but completely
unacceptable
and
he was sort of suggesting that she was
wrong to enjoy the art something from
her background was wrong to enjoy the
arts drinking champagne within the law
as opposed to industrial law breaking at
the heart of governments associated with
partygate
yeah interesting stuff the wink was a
big part of it had to say i was trying
to work out if he was winking at angela
raynier or if he was winking at someone
else on the opposite front bench i
couldn't quite put my finger on it next
time he's on the show i'm going to try
and ask him because the wink definitely
stood out to me
as well i have to say right let's bring
in john comerford shall we your
conservative supporter you're talking to
us from uh kent and what did you make of
today's pmq's did you enjoy it
i thought it was entertaining but
personally i didn't think there was a
winner either side i think there was too
much chewing and throwing
and i just didn't enjoy it i thought it
was like going to the theatres to see a
play and the understudies taking part
instead of the stars and
it just didn't it just didn't do it for
me today
and do you think that was just because
you knew that they are not you know the
top dogs if you like all because you
just thought the i guess the debate
itself wasn't quite up to scratch
i thought the debate wasn't very good i
i thought there was too many personal
far away from both sides
i'm not a great fan i must confess to
either either don mclargo or angela
rainer but
i don't think there was a winner out of
the two of them as far as i'm concerned
there you go
right i want to bring in uh roy now roy
roy a conservative vote you're talking
to us from kent now roy i'm interested
what did you make of the wink what did
you think of uh the the infamous dominic
rav wink
i thought it was quite funny um and i
also thought immediately it happened
that there are going to be people are
going to call it sexist they're going to
call it misogynistic they're going to
call it
uh it's all pretty facile really it's
it's um
um
it was just funny um i thought he hit
him he hit a good point like you
apparently he wasn't winking at her he
was looking at somebody else who made a
comment that she had just made and it
was it was almost acquiescence yes
that's that's that's a good point very
funny so
angela rainer is very very good at
weaponizing class at weaponizing um and
i think going back onto the blind board
thing that's what dominic rob was really
talking about the hypocrisy of on the
one minute saying
you're all posh this and that and then
at the next minute sitting there
drinking champagne and blind boy when
she should be trying to sort out the
real workers strike so
yeah
winner loser
it was very entertaining i don't think
there was a particular winner either way
but it was very entertaining i did enjoy
it i must admit um for once i thought
most of the time
it was about politics it was about
playing the ball not the man or woman
sorry
um so
in in that rece in that regard i thought
it was quite good um and then the
debate on
abortion i thought um was was uh well
had
interesting we'll be talking about that
a debate on abortion uh later on as well
we've got rosie duffield on the program
it did feel like a particularly electric
pmq's i guess didn't it and let's talk
to hannah now shall we hannah walker
you're also talking to us from a dorset
you're a labour supporter is angela
rainer your cup of tea hannah
i think she's usually i think she's
considerably better at the dispatch box
than um
kia stammer
and i think her ripostes are much
quicker and much more to the point than
he makes he reads from a script i
actually thought that today's
um
exchanges were a lot better than than
usual
um and i thought the understudies were
better than the main act um
i also thought that if we're talking
about hypocrisy the
hypocrisy of accusing angela rainer of
going to
the opera
um to do that legally as opposed to the
many many illegal parties in downing
street
was was a bit much but i thought i
thought the exchange was much more
um
appropriate and they both
i didn't think i'd say this about
dominic rob but
they both seem to know their brief and
they seem to have a respect for each
other which is sadly missing most of the
time on the floor of the comments yeah i
think i agree with you though it's funny
isn't it because in some ways angela and
dominic rob you think they would be at
it like cats and dogs that they would
you know hate each other but they seem
to have a they both seem to be quite
enjoying it today even though they
definitely got stuck in on some of those
points uh right let's finally let's
bring in uh linda campbell shall we
you're a swing voter you're talking to
us from twickenham in southwest london
uh what was your take on today's prime
minister's questions
i would say that angela won on
feistiness she's all revved up
and um dominic won on being cool calm
and collected
and i could imagine him as the prime
minister i wasn't so sure about angela
but she definitely was revved up fired
up
and uh he took it well he's very calm
and collected and that's a quality
that is good as well so i don't know who
won i think they won for different
reasons so they both won
and i think that
you know you hear the same subjects
coming up and um facts are
repeated and you just think okay let's
see some action not just hear all the
factuals we want to see things change
interesting stuff well it felt like the
majority of you uh enjoyed it today
quite a lot of praise for both sides but
across party support uh interesting to
see uh from the understudies thank you
very much as always from a really really
entertaining uh panel now if you do want
to join our viewers panel as well and to
give your take
live right here on sky news it's really
easy to do so uh all you have to do is
to email the take with sophie ridge at
sky dot uk the take with sophie ridge at
sky dot uk and include your name your
phone number a little bit about your
political opinions as well really
important because you want to hear all
perspectives and takes on how the world
works so don't be afraid to get in touch
and you could hear back from the team
shortly i do hope you'll consider that
now it's been a really important away
from
global response uh to continuous
enhanced uh forward presence as you know
the uk is there in in estonia uh we're
there in poland we've uh we're helping
out in in romania we're with air
policing we've got uh ships in the
eastern mediterranean we're moving uh
support uh to that area but what we're
also doing with uh the eastern european
countries with the baltics is offering
long-term uh support partnership to help
them build up their defenses and and
make sure they can repel any attack
immediately there you go i wasn't
actually expecting that but actually
quite
timely considering our next guest um you
can see there the prime minister talking
there at the nato summit about what
needs to be done to try and bolster the
support
for some of the people in the of course
affected uh region and our next guest we
can certainly talk
about uh some of those really important
uh issues uh with uh we're joined now by
a man who knows a thing or two about the
armed forces and geopolitics the former
deputy chief of the defence staff at the
mod senior advisor and overseas envoy
for the prime minister sir simon nail
thank you so much for being here
we loved it sue with us um i'm really
interested to get your take on
what is happening in ukraine because it
felt feels to me
like we had you know some months where
the story was really about russian
failures you failed to take
a failure to make progress whereas
more recently
they have had some successors in the
east haven't they what is the current
situation is russia yeah i i think
tactically and you've you've covered it
many times sophie the ineptitude of the
russians their complete disregard for
casualties their own or civilian
casualties has been hugely highlighted
you know very very large you know body
bag count very very large numbers of
tanks destroyed uh real exposure of
their failures in command and control
etc
but operationally you know they have
great depth
um the russians historically have a
great capacity for suffering um you know
whether it's the second world war or
whether it's uh
you know the the soviet union they their
capacity to just keep bulldozing on or
steamrolling is there we must not
underestimate the uh putin's
determination to get something out of
this and we should not again
underestimate how important what he's
got already is the donbass um mario paul
the ports there what he has obviously
failed to do is either overthrow the
government take kiev uh or take odessa
and i think that's going to be beyond
him but then strategically we're in the
business of how much are the
consequences of the
invasion going to play out or the
consequences of the sac the sanctions
against the invasion um as as that as
that as we move through the year and
it's very difficult to see a really
comfortable outcome even though support
is there in nato i think the madrid
summit's been up extraordinary
change in in the la you know take five
years ago yeah uh but issues to do with
china issues to do with the african
union issues to do with
india
you just got to keep opening the
aperture and getting a bigger map i'm
interested when you're saying about the
russian determination to get something
out of it
and i think
you're obviously saying that you know
they've had to recalibrate some of their
ambitions
but does it feel inevitable that russia
will take the dumbass and do you think
they will effectively try and hold on to
that yes i do
and now all the in the the intelligence
expertise will tell you if we continue
to arm
train the ukrainians we may reach a
stage where the russians are so eroded
because they've put everything in the
front window
it's been suffered enormous amount of
attrition we could get to a position in
nine months that's a long way away
in which the ukrainians would be able to
go onto the offensive now whether they
it's an offensive that could take back
the donbass
and you know you are left with a very
very tricky long-term problem and the
question i guess
some people may say that look
we cannot reward russian aggression they
should not be allowed to keep any
ukrainian territory and it's really
important to send that signal others i
guess might argue look we need to end
this war and end the suffering
would a compromise be to allow russia to
keep the dumbass what's the answer well
this of course is where general patrick
sanders a veil friend of mine who have
great confidence as the new chief talks
about 1937.
it's in between the rhinelands
crimea
and the sedating lands
let russian aggression hold on to the
donbass
and the question then is do we go into
1939 an all-out war or do we step back
to sort of 32
where we we manage this what's your take
i
of course i would want to go back to 32.
but it is a very different one and we
keep talking about we see solidarity now
but if you take that nine month time
frame in which the ukrainians could go
onto the offensive
that's an awful lot of that's an awful
lot of water to go under the bridge in
terms of
famine control of grain supplies
fertilizers energy shortages
uh costly living crisis you know and and
we all know that um you know just
historically uh you get hunger problems
or rise of staples you get social unrest
you get political implications so
really really wicked problem as we
describe it for our policy makers and
not a good time to be hitting us
postcovide
with a sort of as i say you know you
know
deficits debts etc given the government
has committed to support ukraine do we
need to increase defense spending
also in light of course of russian
aggression uh i would argue yes uh in
the sense that governors to choose
we've had a sort of 30-year holiday from
history
we have taken the peace dividend all the
way back to 91
reinvested in the welfare state all
sorts of things i totally understand but
eventually
grown-up governments mature democracies
need need to work out where they're
going to prioritize
and explain it to a population now this
is not for britain alone um and as we've
we've been better than most i think in
in
you know
continuing to invest in in our armed
forces
many of our european colleagues i'm
afraid of being free riders
the difference i would argue again of
course between 1937 and now if you're
going to use an analogy is of course
then it was a very weakened leak of
nations
luckily we still have nato which very
much is underpinned by american uh
american uh you know
power and might on that uh sikkim derek
the former national security adviser
wrote in the telegraph this week that
nato should prepare for the risk that
vladimir putin may at some point resort
to nuclear weapons do you think that he
could be prepared to use them and could
the uk potentially be a target
i would suspect uk wouldn't be a target
that is complete speculation
but the the levels of escalation for the
russians
and the soviets before them compared to
ours has always
what's going to say grade the area
between conventional weaponry
unconventional weaponry chemical weapons
and even nuclear so i would not
you'd have to factor in the mentality of
putin his armed forces this sense of
grievance this sense of being cornered
the sense of being in a
western gain up on the russians and that
and that sort of mystical transcendental
approach they have to uh the blood and
soil of russia so it is worrying but we
should absolutely at least bear it in
mind as a as a possibility
really important uh stuff thank you so
much for being on the program and really
giving us that insight into this global
matters thank you thank you very much
now it's our regular chance to speak to
batman champion as we pick our pmq of
the week that's the one that really
caught our eye during the session
earlier and today it's this one
so far this year 52 women have been
killed in the uk
our rights to free speech safe spaces
fairness in sport and even the words we
use to describe our own bodies are all
under threat will the deputy prime
minister send a clear signal as some of
his cabinet colleagues have done this
week that britain respects the rights of
women and will he accept the cross-party
amendment to his forthcoming bill of
rights which enshrines a woman's right
to choose in law
they see duffel there now of course
usually the questioner doesn't get a
chance to respond to the answer they got
and the idea is we're going to try and
put that right each week let an mp do
just that now the question was from
rosie duffield the labour mp for
canterbury who joins us now good to have
you on the program
and now you alluded to lots of the sort
of current debates about women's rights
so in uh the question there and but with
the overturning of roe versus wade it
feels right to really focus on the
abortion issue yeah many people are
going to be concerned about it
why do you think that we need a specific
right to abortion in the uk because we
don't have that i think a lot of people
think that that is enshrined in uk law
that right to choose body autonomy but
it isn't we have laws go back and they
go back over 50 years which say that you
can only be prosecuted in circum certain
circumstances if you do have an abortion
they're completely out of date but but
having it enshrined some of us in the
party feel that and across the house
actually feel that having enshrined in
this so-called bill of rights might be a
way of just of just getting it down and
and putting it on the statute books for
once and for all no you didn't get the
pm's answer because obviously he was out
the country what did you make of
dominick robb's response to you i think
it was pretty measured he was very kind
to me which which i wasn't expecting but
um but i understand his argument is
going to be that actually we don't need
it to end up in a potential courtroom
situation but i think given your
introduction and given that women are
feeling at the moment so worried about
this you know okay it's america we've
got very different political setup but
there's that saying isn't there that
when america sneezes britain catches a
cold and a lot of women are really
frightened about this and we've seen
some things in the house this week that
have made them even more nervous that
people are out there to try and overturn
their rights um you mentioned there
about uh dominic rob talk about it
getting started up in the courts and
actually you know speak to rachel mclean
earlier on the program who is someone
who is you know pro abortion rights but
she said that she believes in the
current situation
is there a worry
that if it is
effectively put in the bill of rights uh
then you know it's something that could
be then challenged in the courts and it
could be judges who decide it rather
than mps yeah i mean that is an issue of
course it is but the bill of rights is
something that obviously the labour
party disagree with it's been banging
around for quite a few years now michael
gove i think first introduced the idea
and we're not going to stop that bill of
rights there are supporters who are
saying why are you putting down
amendments we're against this as a party
and membership but we've got to try and
watch it down somehow and it feels as
though it might be a gateway to eroding
those rights just getting them on paper
would make lots of women feel more
secure at least you say about you you're
worried about the rights being eroded
like i guess is that because you feel
that many women have looked at what's
happened in the states and thought you
know these are things that we thought
were decided and yes things absolutely
fragile one of my colleagues raised a
point that if a british woman goes on
holiday in america maybe not knowing
she's pregnant perhaps in the early
stages and might have
suffered with an ectopic pregnancy or a
complication that just to get treated in
america would probably make your
insurance null and void and they could
even refuse treatment that's actually an
issue for british women or people from
around the world who might happen to be
pregnant and going on holiday so it does
affect other women not just not just
americans but there are a lot of
americans very effective
and currently it's legal in the uk to
have an abortion up to uh 24 weeks of
pregnancy if you were going to include
this fundamental right to abortion in
the bill of rights would that time limit
still be the same there wouldn't be a
time limit on that but that's not
actually what we're thrashing out and
talking about and all of these things
are
sort of up to people to vote with their
conscience it's it's a free vote so
parties wouldn't vote but that bit
wouldn't be in it
i guess doesn't it so does that mean
that under the legislation you would be
able to have an abortion
right up throughout your pregnancy i
doubt it i doubt we go that far but at
this stage i mean there isn't even a
date set for the second reading yet of
this bit of rights so i think we're way
off kind of thrashing out those details
at the moment not we're not doing that
are you worried though that some people
might find it more difficult to support
it if they felt that it would open the
door against a later term i absolutely
understand that and that is something we
need to discuss in the house in detail
and we need to try and do it in a way
that protects everyone's right to an
opinion it is an opinion and it's a
feeling and often people's religious
identity is very caught up in that and i
respect that completely
what have you made of the you know
debate in the house because there has
been i guess some attention given shall
we say into
uh some
of the comments by mps i absolutely
understand i was raised a catholic it
would be very difficult for me
personally to have a termination but i'm
really privileged compared to some of
the women in america who don't have a
choice and there's also issues like rape
you know why should a woman be forced to
do that and my belief is as an mp i have
to put the rights of my constituents and
all women who are affected before my own
religious upbringing which you know is a
matter for my conscience i think all of
us have to have to feel like that when
we're in peace it's a tricky one have
you had any direction from the labour
leadership
um
not yet but i think he did make a
comment didn't he when when this was
overturned that he was supportive of
women's rights as did the prime minister
okay thank you very much for being on
the program really interesting to talk
about you know such a huge issue and
something that lots of mps i may feel
very strongly about thanks
you're watching the take uh you we are
live in westminster up next we're going
to be rounding up everything we've heard
and do a bit of pace match analysis
[Music]
hello welcome back live to westminster
you're watching
the take well we've had lots of takes
this evening on a whole range of
different subjects from ukraine to
abortion and to winking dominant rob
let's have a little post-match round up
shall we with our deputy political
editor sam coats who is here again
no winking please on the programme sam
now it's interesting isn't it because
if you rewind to those by-elections
which was a week ago right most prime
ministers would not have survived losing
those two by-elections one of the
biggest swings or i think the biggest
one we've ever had in a by-election and
yet here we are
is boris johnson you know teflon what's
going on it is extraordinary because not
only that um
and the wakefield by election i think
can be put down to the kind of uh the
numbers of the swing uh which took the
seat from the conservative labor uh i
think probably could be put down sort of
midterm blues but that tivoton and
hollison by-election which was
extraordinary essentially overturning a
27 000 uh liberal democrat deficit to
the tories in favor of a liberal
democrat majority of about 6 000 i mean
that's
horrendous that's not midterm please um
and the reaction from that and it's all
been weird because boris johnson has
been on the biggest overseas longest
overseas trip since the 1970s so
he is not here and not facing his mps
but i've been talking to lots of the
rebels some of the 148 that voted
against him in that vote of my
confidence in the last couple of days
just to take the temperature on the mood
um and amongst that were able group it's
actually they're quite down they're
quite depressed they don't see what they
could do there's no plan there's no
timetable there's no mechanism for
getting rid of him there's no successor
still they're not sure whether the
privileges committee inquiry into
whether he lied more details which we
had today there'll be hearings in
september is going to deliver what they
want to see uh and they don't see what
else there could be it may be that you
have to wait 11 months for another vote
of no confidence and then you're almost
in general election territory and that
will be the argument that boris johnson
and his team rely on at that point to
try and get through boris johnson gets
through day to day but the rebels are
thinking it's quite a successful
technique it's interesting isn't it do
you think we would have a different
outcome if um actually we don't have
time sam i'm sorry i'm gonna told him
the answer to that question no no it
would have been a different outcome
interesting stuff you read my mind sam
coates said that is it for the take we
will be back next week another very
pacey show
every week as well wednesday at 9 00 pm
next up it's sky news at 10.
you